or we say Islam is Fault changed my mind
well here's a topic where if you can
debunk this you can debunk all
Christianity it's over it's over yeah
it's over you guys the only way to deunk
Christianity this to exactly y'all y'all
want to hear in gic's career right now
CH this is
it this is it right here ah thanks for
the
dinor
CHS
wow they bless they blessing today
blessing today man on the Lord's day
look at that praise God what's
upam what's up guys what's up man Jesus
was crucified and resurrected man what
you think about that according to who
according to
history I said of who not what um
according to all of the Gospel authors
according to all of the
historians according to the
prophets all of them agree that Jesus
was
crucified so Prophet Adam agrees that
Jesus was crucified Prophet Adam agrees
that the Messiah would come and
suffer Genesis 3:15 that's when God gave
them that prophecy is that actually
something you guys believe that Adam
that Adam got that Prophecy from God oh
yeah
yeah Genesis
3:15 yep the seed of the woman will come
and be bruised while at the same time
crushing the Serpent's head that's in
the story of Adam and Eve that's when
God reveals
that so who wrote Genesis
Moses so how can you change mind on the
crucifixion and resurrection of
Jesus yo why you guys calling me a
nerd we didn't call you we didn't call
you anything no not you guys not you
guys no
um but my question basically who who who
wrote Genesis is where my point would go
but but hold on but H how can you just
prove the crucifixion and
Resurrection I just told you that's
where my point would go where that's
where my point would go that we don't
know if any of the information from the
Bible is accurate and that's the only
source the main source that you guys
have for the crucifixion
information yeah what what what makes
the information about the crucifixion
inaccurate the fact that there's no real
evidence or proof to to actually know
that Jesus was there on the
cross so go ahead no so I'm just curious
so you're so you're saying that you
don't have any arguments against it
you're just looking for the evidences
for it no I'm saying that at the end of
the day the
day when it com as bars when it
to when it comes to the New Testament
when it comes to the new test that's
where information about Jesus comes for
you
guys Old Testament right we just told
you Genesis
3:15 okay but I'm saying I'm saying the
name Jesus right the name Jesus does not
pop up in Genesis I'm telling you when
act Jesus actually talked about and
mentioned and all that right like and
mentioned in the Old Testament he
mentioned him being on Earth being on
Earth mentioned in Genesis he's
mentioned in Deuteronomy he's mentioned
in Isaiah he's mentioned in Zechariah
Malachi
name Jeremiah his name is not any of
those books are you sure his name is not
in Zechariah no no okay let's go to
Zechariah Chapter 6 but even if we do go
there I still want to know what's the
evidence against the crucifixion so like
I'm I was just about to say that and you
keep cutting me off asking me other
questions you know you're getting a
little too excit you're getting a little
too excited buddy I'm getting excited
all right I'm I'm going try to slow down
go ahead I can I can see your smile Slow
Down slow
down yo so basically my point is that
the information about Jesus's
crucifixion about how it happened and
who was there it comes from the New
Testament and the New Testament the only
thing you have of it from Jesus's actual
time is something that's um smaller than
the size of a credit card and it doesn't
have anything about the actual like
pillars of your faith all right I'm
still waiting for the evidence against
it yeah I just told you the evidence you
don't have any reliable source about
what actually happened at the what makes
the source
unreliable I just told you you don't
have anything from the time of Jesus
except a little piece of credit card
paper that has nothing what makes we
have
unreliable you don't know how to like do
you speak
we told you we told you Old Testament
has prophecies there's literally
prophecies that the Messiah will be
crucified that he days later and you
also told me the old was written by
who the old T was written by multiple
prophets but regard regardless of who is
written by it contains the prophecies
and predictions of Jesus's crucifixion
how do you answer that repeat that one
more time I said regardless of who wrote
it it's still contains the Prophecies of
of Jesus crucifixion and Resurrection so
how do you answer
that we're talking about the
old you were saying that he's slow he's
not keeping up you're not bro you're not
keeping up with your like let's try this
again I was just talking I was just
talking about the new I was just talking
about the New Testament and then now you
guys switching them to the Old
Testament you're trying to say that we
don't have anything from time of
and God logic already told you that we
have stuff that you as me
a400
years no
nobody nobody's talking about that you
asked me a question how can you change
my mind about the crucifixion being true
and I told you my response was that all
a majority of the information of how the
crucifixion happened the crucifixion
itself not prophecy ARG CH AR L how you
going know I'm changing if I'm not even
done telling you what it was now you're
saying the majority of your
sources I'm saying majority to to give
you like even a little bit more of an
edge but okay you're not you're not
actually you're not actually answering
the original question the original
question was what's your evidence
against against the crucifixion what's
the evidence against told you what
you're trying to do is what you're
trying to do is you're trying to pull
calls you're trying to pull calls in the
reliability of the Bible that doesn't
tell me the evidence against the
crucifixion what's the evidence against
the cruci I'm not trying to poke holes
in the reliability of the Bible I'm
trying to tell that's exactly what
you're trying to do no I'm just trying
to tell you you have no information on
the resurrection from Jesus's time
that's a valid argument and because you
can't answer it and because you can't
answer it you start waffling and start
mocking and start doing all this extra
stuff who waing you're the answering the
question you're we don't have any
information the only one waffling is you
you're waffling so bad that I just had
to mute you because you're on bot mode
and panic mode just answer the question
dude I answered the question you guys
are doing all these semantics you can't
give me a response semantic dude what
are you talking about first of all you
said that we don't have anything
contemporaneous to Jesus you said we
don't have anything contemporaneous to
Jesus we said yes we have prophecies
that predate when Jesus came to
Earth and I'm suddenly when it comes to
what happened at the crucifixion day
what happened with Jesus you have no
information about it what explain how
that's evidence against the crucifixion
because claiming something is true that
you have no information or evidence to
prove it true so how how does that how
does that disprove it make the logical
connection for me how even if that's
true how does that disprove it because
if there is no evidence for something
happening then it's just a claim in oh
wait wait so the absence of evidence is
is evidence of absence okay so we don't
have any evidence that you're not an AI
you're not you're not just a bot right
now we don't have any evidence that
you're a real person okay so does that
mean that you there's no there's no
evidence at all that you're a real
person there's evidence that's evidence
against you being a person no you're
just doing more semantics no we don't
know you could be an AI you could be
chbt we don't
know so according to you because we
don't have evidence that you're a real
person that's evidence against you being
a real person yeah if that's the answer
you want to give then that's the answer
you want to give I can because your
answers don't make
sense my answers don't make sense all I
said all I said was let me give you one
last chance Kuran you have the
Prophecies of the crucifixion of Jesus
you have the New Testament documents
that record the crucifixion of Jesus you
have Josephus and tacitus and Planet the
younger that all talk about um the
crucifixion of Jesus well Planet the
younger talks about how they worship
Jesus what is your evidence against this
so you have a bunch of people that's
actually talking about Jesus but nothing
from Jesus's time or people around Jesus
to actually say what happened to
him yeah he just repeating
himself
Halal I'mma start off like this Allah
abbar second of all there's no such
thing as real Christians and Jews as of
today y'all have no Torah y'all have
no y Covenant was taken from hold on
hold on and y' exclude the Barnabas
Bible to just shut up you're just on B
mode just like the rest I'm going to
start off by saying Yeshua abbar the
lordy um and risen and risen indeed
Yeshua just means Yahweh just means that
I am it has nothing to do evidence do
what is your evidence against the
crucifixion and
Resurrection bro quit muting me bro you
annoying bro and my God ain't play baby
that's that's my
reasoning my he ask you what's your
evidence against crucifixion you said
your God didn't play baby there is no
crucifixion that that was made up cuz
Judah sold him out of silver listen
listen anyway anyway anyway because y
have so much information on Christianity
why y you get you information about
Judas from why do y'all take out the
Barnabas Bible why y'all don't where do
you get this idea of Judas bro answer my
question bro answer my question I'm
talking to you about your Bible now
sorry ask get my bad goe okay why do
you D something
Happ I don't know guys something
happened with the connection my bad dang
it I keep making these mistakes bro he
made he made me duck down he said I'm
going to start with Allah abbar I'm like
yo
D gotta be careful man I know be careful
on the dog
sorry
um that there was somebody that was
requesting it was
uh the same Barnabas Bible that says
that that Jesus is not the Messiah and
that Muhammad's the Messiah that's the
Barnabas Bible he's talking about yeah
that's the Barnabas Bible he's talking
about okay got you that's written in
Italian Ian he probably believe that he
said there's no real Christians
in
okay that's crazy it's it's Sunday it's
Sunday Sunday man these these weirdos
you know what I'm saying
yeah Sho everyone how are you hey what's
going on how are you my friend
been a while
huh from Israel from the Holy
Land yes I hear you and I hear the the
one was before me and I have to say that
Christian and Muslim have fight so hard
because they didn't they don't look at
their you know Origins our the Jewish
people
us and it's just the Muslims in just the
Muslims and Christians were fighting
he's a he's a he's a Jew by the way
oh okay so so you think it's just
Muslims and Jews Muslims and Christians
were fighting yeah this is how it seems
like in the states and in Europe here we
got you
know the Muslims aren't fighting the
Jews at
all here if we want to get into that in
shortly I will say this is much more of
an Israeli Arab
conflict yeah
this is my opinion about it it's not
when we build the thir
Temple yeah it's I mean so what's the
point that you're trying to make sorry
go ahead what's the point you're trying
to make
no the fight between Christian and
Muslim is much more spiritually than the
one between the Jewish and the Muslim
here in the Middle East and this is why
yeah much more materially you know much
more you know existent and
um this is but for sure it's spiritual
as well but we don't use these tools um
and let me say about
the crucified
and how do you say it resurrected
becoming back
alive I want to take a think about that
because I know Jesus he was in the tal
as well appear and he was among theim
that was making Mir because there was
the the the really really really sadik
we we call them you know much and the
righteous people close to God yes yes
and he was like you know a free mind one
and I really appreciate him about that
but when you talk about the the the
Messiah and his way I wanted to take a
look because as I see the the the the
the Jesus walk on earth and I read the
New Testament he was left about left
about he was mocked he was going
everyone was telling and go out stop
talking your silly your silly things and
this is what they did to us for 2,000
years for the Jewish people around the
world we was always trying to be good to
everyone and everyone was H you know go
loud on us because we you know it's easy
to go to the weak one and then I wanted
to look at something
interesting when we were crucified in
aitz
that H you know where six million Jewish
was butchered and we was on the
cross when the world war was over 45
right uhhuh when the Israeli
Independence you know that yes
48 three years later the Jewish people
Came From the Ashes of aitz and rer
crate or came back for alive in his own
Jewish state it means what I'm trying to
say that the real Messiah and we still
wait for you know the the mashia Ben
David the second coming you call it but
the
second okay the second Comon but where
when you look at the Jewish people
around history you can say they
ath mocked around always the you
know banished and ex you know that the
do you know that the rabbis taught that
the Messiah would come 2,000 years
ago
yes not only not only that but they said
that there's 2,000 years of Chaos in the
world there's 2,000 years of the Torah
and then there's 2,000 years of the days
of the
Messiah right so the rabbis are saying
that the Messiah was supposed to come
2,000 years
ago oh he's gone okay
it's God yo shout out to Rob God bless
you rob thank you for all the the gifts
okay um Eden do you know do you know
that the that the the talmud teaches
that the Messiah was supposed to come
2,000 years
ago oh he keeps going he keeps
leaving you hear me man I can hear you
now not when you leave the app though ah
okay no no I got a call yes I know that
the tal said that 2,000 years ago the M
was need to
come years of Messiah not that 2,000
years ago he needed to come but the
2,000 years of the light of the Messiah
the the the days of the Messiah yes the
Messianic era that's what we're living
in now because the Messiah came and he's
going to
return you know the says the T you know
and and and the prophets it says that
the Messiah he's going to come riding uh
he's going to become riding on a on a
donkey you know the you know the verse
Zariah yes okay now there's another
verse that says that the Messiah and
even the T interprets that to be it says
uh the mashiah Ben ysep and mashia benid
he's going to come ring on the cloud no
you know that okay yes continue yes yes
so the talud says that these two
prophecies are going to happen they say
if the world is entirely righteous if
it's entirely good then the Messiah will
come riding on the clouds then they say
if the if the world is entirely evil if
it's entirely Wicked then he's going to
come riding on a donkey right so they
take the two prophets and they say only
one of
these yes yes he's he he said they take
these two prophecies and they say only
one of them is going to come to pass
either the Messiah is going to come on
the clouds if the world is Holy and good
or the Messiah is going to come on a
donkey however both of these are
prophets of God both Daniel Daniel and
Zariah they're both prophets of God so
they're both telling the truth so the
Messiah came on the first time he came
riding on a donkey but when he returns
he's going to be riding on the
clouds okay so what I want to say to
about these 2,000 years of era is 2,000
years of the people Exile around the
world this is the how we find our really
really really
messic Prospect of the world because we
always live in your Shadow the Christian
and we hear that the massiah is already
come and that we is nothing we need to
do and then we thought to ourselves no
we don't talk about this m because when
M will come the world will
be you know what the rabbi say do you
know what the rabbi say why the M didn't
come 2,000 years ago no yes they say
they if you look at look at rashi's
commentary you know Rashi can yes for
sure okay you look at his commentary on
the on the the um the the text of the
tud where it says that that the Messiah
was supposed to come 2,000 years ago and
he says that we missed it because of our
sin because of our sin we missed it so
the Messiah was they say the Messiah was
supposed to come 2,000 years ago but we
missed it because of our
sin so we say to you yes yes the sin
what was the sin the you know you know
why the T says why the temple was
destroyed was the
biggest because of baseless hatred it
says yes and you know the Psalms the
prophecies that of the Messiah they say
that they hated me without a cause
that's what Jesus said the Messiah Jesus
said that Yeshua the Messiah he said
that he said that they hated me Without
a Cause
M so this was the sin this was the sin
of the people at the time not all the
Jewish people because all of the first
followers of Jesus they're all Jewish
all of them are Jewish his mother is
Jewish all of the followers are
Jewish the majority of H if I was back
in that time I was maybe agree with you
that he was the Messiah but how the yes
yes but how the image of his face now
2,000 years ago helps you to bring
to bring the Messiah the real the real
Messiah because if I'm waiting for a
messiah and you waiting for a messiah as
well we are not in the change but we are
in the same position but you are always
remind yourself that the M already come
and I always we tell you why I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why throughout
throughout the Bible in the tanak in the
Hebrew Bible it tells us that the
Messiah has to come during the time of
the second temple the prophets say that
he's going to visit the temple and this
Temple the the temple the second temple
is going to have more Glory than the
glory of the first temple how is this
second temple going to have more Glory
than the first temple It also says in
Daniel Daniel says that when the Messiah
comes he's going to anoint the holy
place so all over it's telling us that
the Messiah is going to come he's going
to do something with the temple the
second temple the time of the second
temple so the Messiah had to have come
in that era other second temple so we
know that Jesus is the Messiah because
he did the first part we know so we can
have confidence he's going to come back
and do the rest of
it does it make sense does it make
sense okay maybe if I even if I go with
your logic I still don't
um what's that understand you guys
because you know we got a lot of flesh
and blood that we have appreciate that
we said yes this was the Giants of our
people of our faith and like Rashi you
mention him and this is our new
testament
the that you know it's coming from a
generation to a generation to a
generation to a generation but you as I
see lock your Messiah on a one
perspective on a one face on a one book
and didn't let him to come alive as I
said how we did in the this 2,000 years
of Exile we left and learn and learn and
seek him everywhere and now the is
already come if you ask me the M maybe
wasel when he started the No he was an
atheist yeah why not
because is not this is not the point
maybe Joseph when he was go to Egypt and
rule the whole world he didn't was a
connection for the
Israel really about that but
need to bring all the Jewish people
together and he did that but never mind
as
said no I'm a Jewish Son of God like you
you're a Son of God okay okay so so you
know you know you know the you know the
kabad you know the kabad LA yes you know
they believe they believe that their
leader was the Messiah right you know
that
yes Messiah
yes I know there is a lot of criticism
about them as well yes you you still you
still consider them to be Jewish stuff
even though they believe that their
Messiah is the the the
rabie yes what but yeah this is because
you know they kept as minimum the the
the the faith between Abraham and God
and then you know cut their penis how do
you say it
circumcision yes circumcision
yeah uh but let me let me I just want to
respond to to something that you were
saying so this this oral tourah that
you're talking about from you say you
have it from Moses you know you know the
the Jewish community of Ethiopia you
know about this Jewish Community right
yes when when they when they first began
to interact they saw that they had many
many many different practices from the
ashkanazi Jews from the Jews of Europe
from the Jews of the Middle East from
the Jews all over they had these very
different practices and they thought
they they said the same thing we got
this from Moses we got this from Moses
we got this from Moses so what I'm not
hiding for you know I'm hiding for
it so you're all claiming to be from
Moses but you all have so many different
traditions and some of them even
contradict each
[Music]
other you still there and H Christianity
they they they always you always looking
for the real who is the real who is the
real original who is the real original
me on you and then you stuck 43,000
years ago we Jewish developed we let our
Torah to become part of the world as the
world changeed the Torah change with it
and without the erase what was before
and you know you mentioned the TM maybe
you didn't tellar the story that Moses
was traveling in time that he didn't
understand why someone do a thing like
that like in the time of RAB AKA and
Jesus by the way yes and then he heard
RAB AKA said when he was asked why we do
this and this Mitzvah that way and he
said this is this is what we told from
Moses from Mount Sinai and Moos and when
Moses heard that he was satisfied ah
they said I told them that
soou my head as
well but this is the point you have
endless Endless River of Truth this book
is an
[Music]
endless that's what you say
right yes okay so what this means is
both of these things are the words of
God right both of these things are the
word of God this and this are both the
words of God so here's the problem when
you have two different Traditions that
contradict each other how can you say
they're both from God when they
contradict each other
because God is everything so God God can
we we as in human you can't see the
whole see but God is and this is how
Judaism even do one way and do the other
way hello yes how can it be from God if
they both contradict they can't they
both can't be true yeah I'll give you an
example like like let's say that let's
say I want to answer
because I I want to give you an example
I want to give you an example and then
we're we're gonna move on soon okay just
imagine this now you have let's say you
have one of the Traditions that say when
you have your food your meal like your
dinner you say the blessing before you
eat your food and then another TR says
no you say the blessing after you eat
your food it's not before it's after and
then they come and say oh both of the
are from the word of God how can they be
how can they both be
because hello God God created everything
you know God in the name of the real
name Jehovah you call it is the name in
Hebrew is the same letters of hav and it
means in translation for translation it
means reality so when God it's from
shows up inside the
world I have a question I have a
question two two Traditions yes wait a
minute no no just let me finish a little
bit go ahead so when you see the ashas
in theik doing this different thing for
the same guy then you say how can it be
and yet they consider themselves in the
same religious in the same people in the
sameel this is what we called in the
tal as you can see in the it's all about
arguments it is all about arguments one
Rabbi said one that one Rabbi said and
we are got our a
contradiction all all and live with that
we can live with we don't need hear us
can you hear us we're gonna we're gonna
go ahead and move forward um but thanks
for coming up man it's been a while
we're gonna go ahead and it was a
pleasure God bless you and Sh have a
great year a Jewish is coming up
one thing
go before you Goan one thing before you
go can one thing before you go can you
tell me one thing before you go yes yes
for sure say
[Laughter]
say God bless us let's choose
good is coming no the Messiah came he
will come again
but you want him to come again so in the
same position I told you Kai Kai right
you can call me Kai yeah Kai means
living that's okay anyway uh okay yeah
he's gone love you Adon just got to
bring up the next guest my
brother by the way that was a song that
the the Israelis they made about uh like
many years ago anyway there anyway never
mind you into another topic but yeah we
have a Mone now so yeah
[Music]
hello what are they what are they saying
in
Arabic uh his name is
just RHA you have to
unmute he says in the bio may God bless
our Master Muhammad and his family and
companions oh he must be Shia
yeah yeah he is oh he is yeah he he must
have he must have heard us singing about
NOA and he got all
offended all right well come back up
when you're when you're ready to to
unmute and stuff I don't I don't I don't
understand that probably just came up to
just see how how long can I waste
time um only oh you were thinking about
the song are you talking about the song
or the guy's name no yeah the guy's name
yeah okay all right let's see what we
got you made it into a song
bro can I get it
amen
amen someone said that Jehovah's R wants
to talk to us and let him come up yeah I
don't mind the Jehovah when is coming up
Jay you there
Jay all
right these guys request up and then
they're not ready to actually lock you
know what I mean yeah stay up
here only allowing people who disagree
y'all only people who disagree man cuz
I'm trying to get them to where I'm
coming
from that's yeah because the Jehovah's
Witnesses actually they do disagree on
the resurrection they don't believe in
the bodily Resurrection right exactly so
who's the Jehovah's Witness in here that
wants to come up who's the
moderat if y'all see the Jehovah's
Witness that wants to come up I don't
know who he is so just go ahead and
bring him up whenever you want let me
see Clinton
what's up what's going on
Clinton yo how's it pretty
good it's been a minute I've been
watching your lives for quite a while
now and I've been enjoying it I'm
learning so much praise God praise God
so but I I am a Christian so you can
drop me okay I think I requested by
mistake
okay all right right I just got one
question
[Laughter]
just love you brother yeah guys if you
disagree only request if you disagree
please um I let the guy name
Muhammad I request if you disagree guys
uh if you agree go ahead and take away
your request if I see a cross okay um if
I see a cross in your bio
I know that you're most likely a
Believer so not going to bring you
up what's up how you
doing how are
you I'm good I'm good yes good good good
what uh religion are
you I'm a Muslim and I disagree with you
the topic yeah okay okay okay well
welcome to the panel um tell me why why
do you
disagree to be honest if you think Jesus
was God this is the first reason yeah if
you think Jesus was crucifiction
crucifixion pardon yes yeah we're
specifically talking right now about the
crucifixion and Resurrection do you
disagree with that yeah yeah of course I
disagree with that yeah
my first reason to be disagree yeah yeah
yeah I'm trying right
now because if you think he was God then
it's a
blasphemy okay it's a
blasphemy your God is
crucified that's kind of
blasphemy if I ask you what's your let
me finish and if I ask you uh what's
your feeling um about that I don't know
if you're or not that's that's a mystery
to me the second one the second one the
second one do one at a time one at a
time so one it's not blasphemy the the
scripture says that God himself will be
pierced and that when um the Israelites
will look upon him they will mourn and
be feel guilty when they see the one who
they pierced this is 12:10 Yahweh God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob he says then
they will look on me on him whom they
pierced they will mourn as if one as one
uh who Mourns for over their uh over
their firstborn child so it's not
blasphemy it's actually
scriptural that's that your
interpretation Jews never accepted that
no no they do they even say that that's
about the Messiah and uh if you're going
to go with Jewish interpretation if
you're going to say that that's your
Authority then you have to say you have
to reject Jesus as a messiah if you're
going to say that Jews is your Authority
so do you reject Jesus as your Messiah
I'm not I'm not but that's that's the
other the other thing so don't bring up
so don't bring up Jews then so what is
your what I mean you because because you
interpret their their books that's not
your book well actually it's not me that
interprets their
books we are Muslim we not using their
book hold on I'm not I'm not
interpreting the Jewish books it's the
Jews that interpreted the books because
the followers of Jesus were Jews they
are the ones who applied these
prophecies to Jesus who learn from Jesus
and the Holy Spirit Jesus was a Jew who
said that these scriptures are about him
so I'm just repeating what the Jews said
the believing
Jews so if you were there let me ask you
this question if you were there and
Jesus was crucified do do you what do
you feel actually I mean with
this we feel were asking about your
arguments against the
crucifixion yeah I have the second
actually but it's not yeah we're not
trying to do Dr Phil show like how do
you feel about this how do you feel
we're trying to say what's your evidence
what's your arguments against the
crucifixion and resurrection of
Jesus well the second the second reason
is um you know this is like an do you
know you do you know exactly that there
is two evidence yeah internal evidence
and external evidence this this story
crucifixion of Jesus is only in internal
evidence of Christianity that's not true
if we look back let me
finish
we
yeah
let I'm saying I'm saying we'll let you
finish a point but the first part was
wrong so we had to correct you with that
yeah I know I know you you you you you
will not going to accept my my opinion
but let me finish let me finish is
Josephus the New Testament is Josephus
the New Testament
yeah I can go there okay well go there
because it just proves your point we
have Roman graffiti Roman graffiti
mocking Jesus on the cross that's
archaeological evidence not the not
within the Bible not within the New
Testament are you familiar with
that I'm familiar with all of those
story I'm I'm familiar with Fus Josephus
tus Lucian I am familiar with the
historians okay let's stop lying then CU
now now you're lying before we could
have ched up to ignorance but now now we
know you're lying what's the point of
flying here what's the point that's a
good question why you doing it that's a
great
question so my study I've learned it
okay go ahead sorry okay let's let's go
for one by one let's go one by one okay
let's go to the internal evidence let's
go to the history do you know do you
know the story in the crucifixion which
is so awkward for me or maybe for
historians for example like when Jesus
was uh captured by I mean he want go go
to the jail or go to the jail uh he went
to the jail I'm sorry but then the the
the story that the Pilatus want to
release Jesus Barabas this is awkward
story do you agree with that awward
story why is it awward story awkward
story because you you will never find
anywhere anywhere you will never find
anywhere in justice system if
you one second because before you talk
about why uh it's awkward for you you
mentioned that it's awkward not just for
you but also for historians now here's
my question do historians agree that
Jesus was crucified tried under Pontius
pilot who who his storing you said if
you talk about you said historians find
this awkward the story awkward along
with you yeah do these historians agree
that Jesus was crucified under Pontius
Pilate some of them agree some of them
are not all right so which of these
historians which of these historians say
Jesus was not crucified under Pontius
Pilate name
one uh let's say who say Mii Mii
Mii if I'm not mistake Mii who's that
g a historian can you can you bring can
you bring us his uh his work and quote
and who and who agree with that is bman
bman agree with the crucifixion but he
disagree with Resurrection he said he
said judge Murray what
who he said Mo Mory I think he said Jim
Mory or something like did you say Jim
Mor
probably said maybe James Mor I don't I
don't I don't know who that is yes it's
probably his book is uh Paul and Jesus
probably if I'm Mist yeah can you bring
us his quote please that he says that
Jesus was not crucify and also let's go
back to can can I can can you respond my
can can you respond my awkward story you
you made a blanket statement you said
historians you said historians when
anyone makes a statement like that
generalized
statement not a substance right you have
to you have resp you have to response
the I know we don't want to hear about
Judge matthys or whatever else you got
we're asking you when you say historians
you're giving a generalized statement
about what the consensus
is so don't don't back down from that
because you're saying it's awkward for
historians I never I never said it's
consensus no I never said that you said
you said historians I said I said one
perspective and I need your respond you
said the historians I need your respond
you said it's awkward for me and the
historians this story and then I asked
you do the historians agree that Jesus
was crucified you said some of them
others don't and so then I asked you for
a reference you mentioned a guy named
Mory so I want the quote I never I never
intend to gener generalize his storan no
no I never intend to but that's what why
you historian I never intend to but
that's what you did yeah yeah but I
never intend to okay so I'll ask you
I'll ask it again do the historian can
we go there can we get there I get resp
do historians agree that Jesus was
crucified under pontious pilate yes or
no some historian I I already told you
what historian says he's not he wasn't
crucified let's say like
ji give me the quotes that's one I I
just remember once and other you have to
explain what their position is because
you might have someone that's like a
mythicist who doesn't even believe Jesus
was ays even even some historians Think
Jesus was
arents that's exact what I'm trying say
exactly what no no you don't some
historians said Jesus
imaginary he was never exist right
they're notori they're not even credible
they get laughed out of Education they
get laughed out of Academia exactly so
we so give us give us somebody somebody
credible give us a credible historian
that says Jesus was not
crucified that's
your that's not fair brother if you if
you disagree with someone and you can
you call them an
academic yeah that's
that's he talking about one person and
we don't even know who this guy is